speaking of death the left
wants our country to die that sounds
like an over-the-top headline doesn't it
sounds like a parody of what a
conservative might say the left wants
our country to die
well what if i told you that right now
separate from the virus because you know
the virus is
very contagious if you're a conservative
but if you're a leftist gathering by the
thousands in the streets not contagious
at all there are
gangs of leftists gathering around the
country
chanting death to america
take a listen to oakland california
and they are there's a lot of them not
socially distanced
[Music]
if you weren't going to expect some kind
of foreign accent
you could think that that was taken on
the streets of tehran
you could think that that was taken on
the streets of
saddam hussein's iraq you could think
that that was taken
somewhere in the world where people hate
our guts
but it's not it's actually from
california it's actually from oakland
they're not hiding it anymore when colin
kaepernick started his anti-american
protest
now years ago he took a knee for the
star-spangled banner for the american
flag
and i said at the time and i know a lot
of conservatives said huh that's
disrespectful that's very wrong
they said no he's not protesting the
country he's protesting
police brutality he said well that's
kind of weird because the american flag
is not a symbol of police brutality it's
a symbol of
america and he's protesting that he said
no it's police brutality you just don't
understand
he's just doing it for racial justice
whatever that means
then he started protesting the betsy
ross flag then
they started to burn the american flag
now they are chanting out and out
death to america
what more do we need to know you know
there's this thing that we we try to do
especially conservatives try to do this
because we try to be really nice people
we say look the left they love their
country too
we love our country and so we hoist the
american flag and
celebrate america's traditions and
recognize the fourth of july and revere
our founding fathers and
you know so we that's how we celebrate
america
and the left the way they express their
love for america is by burning down the
flag in the entire country but those are
just different ways
of of celebrating your country and you
can't say
that one side doesn't love america i
think if you're chanting death to
america
i'm gonna go out on a limb and say you
don't particularly love
your country now where does this come
from well a lot of it comes from the
racial
hatred that has been stoked that has
been intentionally
pushed by the left by elected democrats
and by the mainstream media and by the
university and by
big tech and by every other aspect of
the liberal establishment
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]